[Musique]
je viens des pays bas donc en partie à
particules et du nord des pays bas et à
la frij monsieur albert d'un est l'un
des gardiens de ce lieu un peu étrange
en février 1871
ils seront nombreux à mourir ici offer
des basses perche
c'est à cet endroit que la guerre est
terminée parce que mon objectif
d'épauler chien s'était donc de
citadelle
cette fois la soirée était le bon pour
les défenseurs de belfort en revanche
c'est le début de la fin laly perche
tombe entre les mains des plus anciens
tout de suite y activent leurs unités du
génie et d'artillerie pour installer
plusieurs dizaines de pièces
d'artillerie sur cette colline à ce
moment-là denfert rochereau et on va
dire est presque acculé à une guerre qui
va être et un bombardement qui va être
terrible mais le colonel qui est en
train de forger sa légende ne cède
toujours pas c'est finalement le
gouvernement français qui lui ordonne de
se rendre à la mi février après 103
jours de siège
la guerre est terminée la france a perdu
mais belfort va rester française
contrairement au reste de l'alsace
[Musique]
l'état français donc on va être obligé
d'accepter de négocier en échange de
belfort est de communes environnantes et
via des communes mosellanes qui vont
être abandonnées sur l'autel de
l'annexion quand on ne mentionne belfort
c'est la place forte avec un rayon de 10
kilomètres autour qui va être détaché du
département du haut rhin pour rester
france puisque nous sommes dans une
alsace qui est considéré comme
francophone donc les prussiens n'avait
pas totalement interac annexé cette
partie du territoire alsacien
le siège de belfort a fait 1600 morts
côté français et des milliers de blessés
les prussiens aurait perdu deux mille
hommes on va créer le mythe du siège de
belfort autour de cette résistance
héroïque qui va indubitablement servir
de modèle à la société française durant
plus de quarante ans jusqu'à la première
guerre mondiale
belfort est le symbole de la résistance
d'une france vaincue mais vaincu d'une
manière héroïque
le lion de bartholdi incarne bien sûr le
courage d'une cité qui va d'ailleurs
prospéré après le siège la ville a connu
un essor sans précédent sur le plan
économique
belfort donc devient une véritable ville
de garnison
c'était beaucoup plus intéressant de
maintenir cette zone en département ce
qui fut fait donc en 1922
aujourd'hui la citadelle de belfort et
un le sanctuaire de cette mémoire dans
dans le nord franche comté
c'est aussi pour ça que bon nombre de
gens viennent ici retrouvés pour
découvrir cette histoire y compris les
allemands parce que c'est aussi leur
histoire
le dernier survivant de la guerre de
1870 sa place séraphin pruvost il est
mort en 1955 il était le dernier témoin
d'une guerre souvent oublié sauf à
belfort ont cent cinquante ans après
denfert rochereau tient toujours sa
position là au milieu de la ville